good morning millennials
back to the toast happy Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday we are capping
off toast friends and family week with
such a delightful gorgeous stunning
guest that everyone loves and I can't
lie I have to be honest like I hate when
you come here thank you so much because
you stunt on these hoes like look at
your shoes look at your whole outfit and
I took so long to get ready today to the
point where it's almost embarrassing
when you see I'm just wearing like a
sweater and pants do you look nice I got
new pink rich
wow I always say that to Taylor strucker
and that's her favorite company that is
her aesthetic she like dresses like a
rich woman but like she only shops at
Zara I'm like you are such an upper east
side rich woman thank you I got new
culottes all for Paige culottes out for
Paige you look stunning tell us about
your outfit thank you okay there's this
website called Source unknown it's not
it's like if Zara had not expensive
prices but like a little bit a little
bit more scale Zara's getting a little
out of control with their prices
um did you see like the jackets for like
300 I was like why don't you calm down
it used to be like all right crazy
pricing there like you would get
something expensive it was like 50 right
and now it's like everything Baseline 79
and sometimes sometimes I'll be like
okay it's a nice jacket it's 150 maybe
I'll get but it's well made but when I
see like 399 I'm like I'll have a word
with the manager that's how you know
these dark Economic Times are really
taking a hit onto everything like Zara
too you see Zara Zara I say Zara I don't
know what I say but whenever I say it I
say differently and I always get yelled
at like I say I think I say Zara I know
a lot of my girlfriends from Long Island
they say Zara and so I like hearing it
it makes me feel like I really do live
in New York what where are you from
originally I'm from Albany like a long
island-ish accent everybody says that
everyone actually always thinks I'm from
Jersey yeah you have like a very
tri-state area like similar to me I'm a
Tri-State well you're from Albany yeah
the nation's cap no the state capital
beautiful part of town you know it
really is I've spent some time there
have you what about on tour I spent like
one night there okay where did you go my
tickets didn't sell well so I never went
back but I went to I played the egg oh
you know the egg I went to a prom at the
egg
my promise at the Latin quarter in New
York and I stayed at the Renaissance
Hotel okay and I want to shout out the
Renaissance in Albany it was a gorgeous
facility wow I've never stayed and they
had Netflix and oh okay this was like on
the first tour it was like four or five
years ago it was kind of like crazy that
they had Netflix don't you love when a
TV at a hotel has is a smart TV yes but
let's talk about Chromecast because I
don't [__] with Chromecast so a lot of
these TVs some of them have built in
Netflix like on the remote it says
Netflix and I feel yeah so privileged
yeah the one percent and then sometimes
they're like you could stream and I'm
like oh great and it's like you have to
download Chromecast on your phone and
then you have to download Netflix on
your phone and Chromecast Netflix then
you can't use your phone while you're
watching TV I went out to LA and I was
like I am going to treat myself yeah I
am going to pretend I'm Morgan Stewart
and stay at the Beverly Hills Hotel oh
my God okay Rich Amazon live paying well
you have to Chromecast
I don't believe you I was like
um pardon that's disgusting isn't it
disgusting you know what's something
I've started to do
it's like kind of crazy but like you
travel a lot you do giggly Squad tour
um when I'm on tour I had a Roku fire
like a stick yep that I brought with me
that had all my log in already wow and I
would like get behind the TV and plug it
in sometimes the TV was like stuck to
the wall and I can't get my arm back
there but a lot of the times it worked
you're living in 2050. and we're all
just mere mortal it was kind of like
like really smart yeah that is actually
very smart how's the giggly Squad tour
going I have not been to a show when I
want to come so we're going next week we
start in Nashville and we're doing like
all of Texas so fun so I'm very excited
for like a western Vibe what are you
gonna wear I have a couple sets picked
out that are very like if I were to go
to Coachella or like Stagecoach
Stagecoach that's what I'm thinking you
shouldn't go to Stagecoach I'm going
this year it's really where is it it's
the same exact grounds as Coachella I've
never been to Coachella that's like
makes you so cool everything is like
effortlessly cool yeah me and Remy was
on the uh podcast made me like an
introvert no no I like fell into
societal pressures two years in a row
and like I'm like a loser and I just
like am desperate for fame and like
acceptance and I think in order in order
to do that like you have to go to
Coachella it's literally why we're here
I just feel like Coachella is a part of
that toxic cycle and I will say like I
had such preconceived notions it was
um something I like hated mostly because
I'd never been invited yeah and the
first year I went Me and Jackie were
like haters and we had such a good time
it was so like we got the hype yeah and
then the year after that we like went
fully prepared and it was more fun but
Stagecoach is so much more fun now to
have people talk about Stagecoach but I
think that's fine it's not like thirsty
well I have the outfit so maybe I will
go and I do like country music a lot of
people like hate on country music I like
it I actually like do have an extra
ticket if you wanted to come I do like
Shannon's coming with us my sister what
are the dates they literally in two
weeks like April 26 to May 1st like that
weekend I can't because we have Summer
House reunion okay well let's talk about
summer house it's kind of like a crazy
season in the sense that like nothing
crazy is happening but people are having
like a lot of discourse like serious
combos people are very mad there seems
to be and I just watched the episode
last night where we're celebrating
Kyle's 40th and like I'm all about you
know age is just a number but like it is
really crazy that there's actually a 40
year old man on this show and how old
are the new girls like Gabby and Sam
like 22. okay so Sam is 25. and Gabby is
I want to say Gabby's 32. okay I thought
Gabby it was younger but like Sam is 25
and like dancing on the kitchen table at
four in the morning like so is Kyle and
it's like there seems to be a disconnect
that a lot of people are like can't get
past okay so you know when Vanderpump we
were like oh you're a silver Vanderpump
they don't even work there anymore
they've grown out of it I feel like we
have hit that point where there's
nowhere else for us to go yeah that
we're like
yeah like we're like because to be
honest like when you go out to the
Hamptons I don't want to drink the way I
did when I was 25. of course I also
physically cannot of course like I will
be vomiting dead and everyone's always
like Paige is always in the bed yes and
I'll never apologize for being
horizontal here's the thing you don't
know who you're talking to like you
quite literally never have to explain
yourself I would I would spend more time
in the bed than you like it's exhausting
social battery wise I get depleted like
I hit my socializing lemon and I'm like
Gotta Go Gotta go see ya that's so fair
and also like I am drinking on the
weekend so like I'm hungover and I'm
sorry that they don't show on TV like me
vomiting yeah but like it happened yeah
no I I totally I don't I don't find
fault in anything that you guys are
doing and you have always spent time in
the bed and so if you're nothing if not
consistent
exactly but we're at this like impasse
definitely where I feel like a lot of I
love the new girls like I love Gabby
even though like I'm so anti-haroscope
to my core well what's your sign oh gosh
shut up my time is cancer don't ask me
about my Moon Rises like I don't want to
know what that is like one of the only
signs that my sign like [__] with
what's your sign I'm a Scorpio is that
November yeah you've seen birthdays
Jackie right I'm November four oh she's
a six okay same thing it's like a
Queenie kind of weird yeah
um Sally Fields is also November 6th
who's your birthday buddy
um Matthew McConaughey Bethenny Frankel
and I think that's up
um remember like birthday buddies were
such like a thing like my birthday
buddies Jessica Simpson okay when we
were like growing up for you like was
birthday buddy a thing like whatever
celebrity I've literally never heard the
term birthday
maybe it's like a niche family thing
that me and Jack you're like I feel like
that is very Niche oh my God my sister
Olivia's was Michelle Kwan like we were
obsessed with birthdays that's Michelle
Quan I agree and we were in the mall in
Florida like when we were all really
young we saw Michelle Kwan and like it
was a big deal because she was Michelle
Quan and at the time it was iconic but
for our family it was like another layer
because it was Olivia's birthday buddy
and I was we were not okay but you don't
do birthday parties I mean I've done
like oh what famous person has your same
birthday but I've never heard it
referred to as birthday buddies but from
this day moving forward I will say who's
your birthday buddy but it wasn't like a
form of social currency like where where
you grew up
maybe it's like not an Albany thing now
guys let me know in the comments like
yeah am I wrong here like I knew but it
wasn't talked about as much as right I
feel like it was and it wasn't like a
level like it didn't add to your
popularity or anything yeah well that's
why I feel like a deep connection to
Jessica Simpson yeah to explain do you
feel a deep connection I do I do I've
always loved her especially because
she's my birthday buddy yeah
um and I felt like so connected to her
in a weird way because of that but also
because I loved her music and I was just
like my God I grew up like during that
time I wish she would have like a
Resurgence did you read her book no I
didn't oh do you read like I'm not a
reader I listen to you and Jackie and
I'm not a reader that's fair I was so
anti so I can totally understand like
when Jackie used to read I used to like
mock her endlessly and that's kind of
the theme at the toast is like Jackie
does things to better herself and like I
make fun of her and then three years
later I do them and I'm like you were so
right you know like watching Downton
Abbey so I'm sad because every time I
come here it's because Jackie can't be I
know and I've still like never really I
didn't count with her and me and Hannah
were talking about this on Tuesday like
in the giggly Squad like you're very
much a Jackie and Hannah's very much a
Claudia and Jackie's totally a page and
I'm totally ahead but literally Jackie's
never podcast with you I don't think
she's ever met you no we've never met
but she loves you we've only ever talked
down in like we're Instagram friends and
I obviously keep up with everything he
does yeah it counts we were sending back
a clip of you guys the other day
cracking up Peggy yes Omar can you tell
that story you told this funny story on
your podcast for those who don't know
she hosts podcast with Hannah from
Tuesday's episode called giggly Squad
and you were talking about how Uber
drivers always pronounce your name
incorrectly but they always call it the
same thing yes so it started when I was
in college and I had this one Professor
that just could never get my name right
and he called me paggy so like but your
name isn't even like complex it's a one
syllable it's one syllable and it's like
also a common word word as in like a
page I just happened to throw an eye in
there right in the middle but a lot of
people do right does anybody spell it
without the eye I've seen it like a few
times where girls have spelled it
without me okay but it's common to have
an eye okay so in college this professor
I was paggy and that's what I went by
and who was I to correct this smart
smart man but a professor like he should
even know like linguistically I think I
did say like on the first day like oh
it's Paige right and he was like we
don't know we're gonna fight I was like
cool I was the caddy Heron right right
right right right so you just do me a
favor bring my microphone a little
closer to your mouth sorry no you're
good
so then when Uber started I got into
like my first Uber and they were like
paggy and I was just like yeah that's
for me and so ever since I've just never
it's like being at the nail salon like
I'm not gonna correct them when I hate
the color yeah I'm not gonna crack them
on my name and they're gonna correctly I
hate the color I'm just gonna go home
and cry like I know I'm not gonna become
friends with the Uber driver right I'm
not worried that he thinks I'm Peggy
yeah that's just so funny that like
their brain a lot like all of them they
collectively go to paggy I would never
even think of that pronunciation I think
the E maybe the e at the end is really
throwing them like even your professor
he would know phonetically if he's like
an educated person that why would be
paggy right for me everyone can
pronounce Claudia right and a lot of
people just assume I'm Latin okay so
they'll start talking to me in Spanish
and I actually do speak Spanish oh okay
but I'll say I'm like not really I'm not
Latin I'm actually Eastern European yeah
um but it's it's odd for sure yeah it's
just like you don't know what to say
yeah so I just go with it are you like a
big conver cursor in Uber
no I weirdly am if they start talking if
I get like a really nice guy who like is
starting to talk to me about like oh
like what's the weather oh what's like
where are you going taking you to the
airport yeah then I will talk back but
I've never started it oh I have what's
your first question how long have you
been driving Uber
or like have you been really busy today
because I always find it like
interesting based on the weather
um but I have that I've asked that
because New York some randomly you're
like where's all this traffic coming
from what's going on and they do know a
lot of insights well that's the other
thing I find that like Uber drivers and
taxi drivers are the eyes and ears of
this city yes and I find like I always
want to take the temperature like
especially when it comes to the Mayors
and I've been living in the city like
since I was in Middle School right so
I've been through Mayor Bloomberg Mayor
de Blasio now mayor Adams and they
always hate the American government
literally
a diplomat a woman of the people and I
always want to know I'm like do you hate
the mayor yeah they loved Bloomberg okay
hated de Blasio like with a fiery
passion and they're pretty much hating
Eric Adams too okay um and I just like
to I want to know what the people are
saying yeah
on the polls when Uber first started I
did actively ask like what's the deal
with the taxi drivers like right you
guys beef it was interesting dynamic
they had a lot to say I was very in on
that gossip yellow taxi drivers want
nothing to do with you nothing and but I
appreciate it I live for it they I mean
they put a wall up quite literally and
you know it's bad when you get in and
then they close the partition like it
was open maybe they wanted to talk to
the person before but not [__] you
[__] but I do appreciate in some
um taxis when they have that really long
metal thing to do the air
yes that's very niche in okay so in this
summer you guys if you've never been in
a New York City Yellow Taxi the front
seat with this like the driver's seat in
the passenger seat right behind it
there's a plastic partition so it's like
nobody can come up and like [__] with
the driver
um there's like a little hole you put
the money through there's a TV
um but it makes it really difficult in
the summer because it's so [__] hot
and the air conditioning usually in the
older ones comes from the front right so
a lot of really generous and thoughtful
drivers will take this like it's like
ducked you know it's like that um it's
like a silver tube and they'll funnel
the air from the front to the window in
the back and I will sit with my head up
that thing I try and get inside of it I
want to live I'm like thinking about
sitting in the front seat in the summer
it's so [__] hot wet you just like
open like a deep recess of my mind those
things talks about it and laughs it's so
thoughtful yeah it really is okay so I
tip them yeah of course because I'm like
thank you but you know the new thing in
yellow taxis and I think why a lot of
them are disliking the current mayor is
the base fare before you go anywhere the
base fare now is like seven dollars
really and that that pushes people to
tip less which sucks because that base
fare doesn't go to the driver it's like
taxes congestion fee and said well that
should be going to the driver right but
it doesn't I went out on a date one time
with this guy and he asked me when
you're in a taxi and it says like 10 20
30 what do you click it's a very good
question and I said well I usually click
20. and he said stop doing that click
30. you'd like their lives are so hard
and they take so much money from taxi
drivers so I don't even remember who the
guy was right but from that day on I
started clicking 30. isn't it funny what
sticks with you like random things
people have said to you that are like
into this guy's inconsequential to your
life like you never like loved him yeah
but weirdly like things people say stick
with you forever do you ever think about
like people that you went to middle
school with and like how you think of
them and then like from one instance
that they probably don't remember and
what's their one in instance that they
think of you I often think about like
what people who knew me in former lives
think about me now especially given what
I do for a living and I'm sure you I
think about it all the time and I
reached out to sometimes but I really
want to know like who hates me I know
like from middle school that I don't
know hates me I think about that a lot I
wouldn't be surprised if like a lot of
people think I was so deeply insecure as
a little girl that I think I projected
that as like being mean like I think I
don't think I was like a really friendly
girl like I had friends and I was like
not interested in making more see I was
like just really shy and quiet oh I was
like loud and annoying so I think I gave
[__] Vibes because I was like nervous
to be anywhere but my bad
is like an adult now you know how many
hours a week would you say you spend in
your bed and be honest because it's a
very safe space oh
um more than half no like I
I am a couch girl too but it hits it
hits a point in the night where I'm like
I'm moving it to the bed yeah where
Craig is a full couch guy oh my God I
hate my couch so he'll make me stay on
the couch till like midnight oh and then
we'll go to the bed we're like at my
house it's like 10 30 we're moving it to
the bed oh 10 30. I'm quite literally in
bed at four o'clock for the night yeah
it's the best yeah like like I go home
to when I go home after this I don't
have anything to anywhere to be after
I'll put my comfies on and I'll be in
and out of the bed a hundred percent but
like doesn't everyone do that it doesn't
but like no it's crazy I can't relate my
couch actually I had my couch for four
years it is in pristine condition I've
never sat on it and I had like um you
know the carpet cleaning couch cleaning
yeah the companies oh that was a very
satisfying story that you were I know he
was great and literally my couch was so
clean and you so you don't ever like
watch TV on your couch unless it's like
a big event not like the Super Bowl but
if everyone's like watch watching
something I might watch it on the couch
just because it's like I don't know I
try to make it like a big Affair okay
okay I know very interesting okay back
to summer house because like I keep
getting off to my channel okay reunions
coming up reunions coming up you're very
much like in a safe space I feel you're
not like majorly apart like Danielle or
yeah I feel like I don't really have
much to answer for yeah but I find this
Lindsay thing so interesting because
like I've been waiting for like the
trial of Lindsay Hubbard for many
seasons and I don't feel like this one's
it like I don't know why Danielle's like
so butthurt about her being in a
relationship with Carl it gives like
weird Vibes to me and like last season
oh my God I was like so not teen Lindsay
and this time I'm like well I don't
really see like what everyone's all
butthurt about yeah I think Dan yeah I
think here's the thing that with summer
house I don't think they ever properly
showed really how close Lindsay and
Danielle truly are like they have been
best friends for six years and I
remember like the first summer I was on
the show and they had gotten into like a
fight about something and I was like oh
my God I feel like they never fight like
their best friends which is so crazy I
remember looking at Hannah being like
what do we say and Hannah was like just
shut your mouth I was like okay so and
that like never that fight never aired
and then like another summer they got
into like a little snafu about something
like stupid right but it's like friends
are fighting yeah
and and I just always felt like wow if
me and Amanda had that they would
immediately go and show it so I don't
think like the viewers know how close
they really were and like certain things
that are underlying like history yeah so
I don't know if Danielle was like mad
that she's certainly not mad she was
dating Carl right
um but I think there were like so many
deeper things that they just couldn't
explain this season because they had it
in the past do you think you will be
invited to Carl and Lindsay's wedding I
have no idea because well one I have no
idea if they're planning I don't know if
she's a bride that's like oh I'm gonna
be engaged for a little or if I'm a
bride that's like immediately planning
so I have no idea you haven't been told
either way like interesting yeah I feel
like you will be if it's going to be
televised that's what I think too
if it's during summer house I would
assume but also like or you like be in
the bed yeah but don't tempt me with a
good time what do they bring the bed to
the wedding okay like I would I would
Lane at the whole time I don't want to
bring this up because I imagine when
people bring it up it's the same way I
feel like when people ask me when I'm
having kids okay um but last time not
last night I watched it last night
Sunday's episode there was like a big
conversation about you moving to
Charleston and you like kind of got
anxiety moving away from your family so
[__] relatable when you started to
cry I'm like yummy too yeah um but I
asked the toasters for questions for you
and people could not get past what you
said on what happens live about Craig
like I think you said he's 7.5 or like
everyone please explain yourself okay
first of all people don't understand
when Andy is even talking to you I
immediately freeze yeah so like every
question I'm like oh and then I just say
something yeah right when 7.5 came out
of my mouth I was like oh my God Craig
is gonna be so sad if Craig said 7.5 I
would have immediately broken up with
him what was the question it was
like how like he also there were so many
words yeah it was like How likely is
Craig the person you're gonna marry is
he the one for you one to ten and I was
like I went middle I was like 7.5 I
don't know it's a tough question like
word wise and then after I think it was
Sierra Sierra said like oh like you're
gonna have to answer to Craig so then I
immediately called Craig he didn't watch
it and I was like watch what I said and
he was like I know basically he was like
I know you're stupid yeah right I know
you got confused and I know your humor
yeah very good so like nothing happened
between me and Craig but I people got
very upset well I think people feel
really like so invested in your
relationship like to another level that
I think you like scared everyone Paige
like Peggy come on I know I was like I'm
so sorry to do that okay everyone's
nerves but like that's good yeah but no
we're fine but the question I didn't
want to ask but it's literally the
number one question we got for he was
like status on you moving to Charleston
so here's the thing too like growing up
obviously I didn't grow up in New York
City but growing up in New York and then
I've lived in the city for 10 years now
the south is so different Beyond and I
don't mean just like oh everyone's
married and everyone has kids like sir
like they just think differently
culturally yeah yeah and it is a big not
only a big change in that but it's also
the thought of having to get on a plane
every time I want to see my mom I know
it's terrifying and when I have children
I want my parents of course to be around
and be able to be there so like
obviously people haven't seen this on
the show but I've talked to my parents
about it like okay if I moved to
Charleston what are you guys going to do
and my mom was like I would have no
problem getting a house in Charleston
wherever you are coming down for a few
months like do not worry about us we
will come to you we will make sure that
you don't feel like we're away that's so
sweet are you an only child no but I
asked like one yeah I have an older
brother but he acts like an only child
got it well that's so sweet of your mom
like isn't that so cute that's so nice
so it really put me at ease good but I'm
also not ready to move I love New York
and I love like I we can't do what we do
really not in New York sometimes so you
could technically still be on summer
house correct you could just spend your
summers in New York yes I could
technically technically still do that
but I could also always just like switch
over to Southern well that was a
question we got for you and I was
curious too like if you did move there
like being a member a cast member on
that show is an option correct for sure
got it is Craig moving to New York which
I know is like not really I don't he
said I think he said that in the moment
because I freaked him out and started
crying and he was like I love you more
and I was like okay all better now great
um but I don't think he would ever like
sell his house in Charleston right if I
said to him like Hey I want to spend
half the year in New York half the year
in Charleston he would totally do that
yeah but he travels a ton too right and
I can say out of all the things we fight
about our long distance really has never
been one of them like we've never felt
like one person makes the effort more
like we like he's flown to New York for
lunch before because like he hasn't seen
me and then he'll like fly back right so
I'm not I'm not as worried as other
people are making me worse yeah of
course but I'm not I'm not that worried
about it okay that's good literally when
we got questions I'm looking at them now
how could we help you let's help Craig
let's move us to New York like people
are gonna literally pack up your
apartment for you that's how invested
people feel it's crazy wow I love that I
have Free Movers thank you literally and
the other question
um that I thought was interesting is
because like you're very much like a
style like icon for a lot of people and
wedding style is so yeah specific people
want to know what your wedding style is
are you classic are you traditional what
are you I actually it's the one thing
that I have no idea I actually brought
up getting married in Italy to Craig's
family and his mom was like no why don't
you get married in Delaware and I was
like where am I getting married in
Delaware so her and I had a little we
went back and forth and I said I promise
that I'll I will make your experience so
lovely fabulous and she said fine okay
but I have no idea Craig really doesn't
want to get married in Charleston yeah
and I don't really want to get married
in New York City I mean they do say that
Delaware is the Italy of the Northeast
so it's kind of similar I don't know if
anyone's ever said that I feel like they
said that could you see me with like a
Pinterest Barn no wedding right like no
and that's the vibe I'd have to do in
Delaware like I feel like you know gen Z
now says weddings are too gay I know um
and it's because they're not Han always
says that's because they're not old
enough to get generous but I think the
the wedding style they're talking about
is that you know Barn twinkly light yeah
more you know millennially aesthetic
I've never been that aesthetic I've
always thought like I would get married
in Italy and have this like very
1960s like famous Vibe that's so Chic
like I love that I feel like Jackie
would also love love like that's so you
you guys can come for sure I was
literally just thinking like
I feel like maybe I can be my dad no you
would absolutely be yeah I would invite
you for sure Craig is obsessed with you
no we're obsessed with Craig like Jackie
specifically I think Jackie feels so
almost like almost like an early like an
investor yeah in Craig because like in
the beginning seasons of Southern Charm
people just used to rag on Craig and
Jackie was like they're wrong about him
they're wrong about him and she was like
really passionate that he was one of the
only ones who was that good to Catherine
when they were so I loved terrible to
her with the Thomas stuff and Jackie
just feels very um yeah because she's
always been right about him yeah and now
it's like everything's coming up Craig
he passed the bar and he's got a big
business and he's got his gorgeous
girlfriend and it's like Jackie saw in
him what we all see in him now but she
saw it years ago sometimes he will say
something stupid and I'll be like it's
so funny that you're like a legitimate
lawyer it's Craig your lawyer like if
you ever got arrested for something like
would you call him can I tell you a
funny story please I got this random
email one time Craig and I were at this
like golf charity event I get this email
that I'm being sued first so flattered
by the way we just got sued I love that
for you guys so I was like oh my god I
think I'm being sued two this guy saying
that like I posted a picture that I
didn't have the rights to the picture
that's quite literally what happened to
us no way yeah it was our whole
Instagram got shut down stop for like a
month oh my God okay it's real you have
to be so careful so I was like what is
going on so Craig read the email and he
was like this is fake don't respond to
it like don't respond to this email but
I couldn't get it out of my head so I
texted my agents and like sent it all
over and they were like okay this is in
fact you are getting sued like let us
deal with it and I looked at him and I
go I would be in jail
I would literally be in jail yeah if you
were my lawyer if I listened to you like
keep practicing your golf swing because
I don't need you anymore what ended up
happening I had to pay so do we because
I was like I tried to do it as long as I
could so that like the statue of
limitations was up literally the same
but then they want to take me to court
and I was like right what would I wear
deactivated our Instagram account so we
kept trying to drag it out but that was
as that was um worse for you right the
longer we didn't have an Instagram
account and it was like 11 photos
so mine was only one what was it of
Sophie Turner pregnant I had posted it
in 2020 when it like her first Paparazzi
picture of her pregnant I'm fairly
certain that was perhaps one of our 11
as well it was probably the same agency
that owns the photo yes and I was like
what a like random yeah so there are
like these companies that like scour
Instagram for photos that are owned by
like different agencies like Paparazzi
agencies and then sues the and they file
claims with Instagram and then they sue
the person and they just like make money
for for these Paparazzi agencies and
they take a fee off the top to get these
photos taken down and to get their
clients paid my agents actually really
humbled me during it because they were
like we can't believe this is happening
to you and I was like I know it's so
crazy and they were like no no like this
only happens to legitimately famous
people and I said thank you so much
you having to pay them was like an
investment in your car yeah I felt like
that lawyer was like manifesting like
yes she Greg needs that energy you know
he could be a little bit more supportive
yes oh man that's so crazy that that
happened to you too that was like a
crazy thing that happened to us but
didn't you feel like so an adult that
you were getting sued no I felt so
panicked yeah because it was so many
photos and if they they didn't want to
go to court and neither did we we were
going to settle but technically like the
highest extent that they could have
charged us per photo like would have
bankrupted us stop it was it was crazy I
wanted I wish you went to court and did
like full Gwyneth Paltrow at like kind
of like Legally Blonde yeah we would
have had Craig represent us
that could have that could be its own TV
show I know and we would have gotten
like so much press it almost like might
have been worth it yeah I like not only
is Craig our lawyer we're like walking
in their pages in the background like
crying like talking I'm so worried I'm
like looking over at the guy drawing
your pictures I'm like that's not double
chin a race a race she's a very strong
sir they always do you dirty in those
court drawings that's why I could never
go I would love to dress on it she I
don't think they do chord drawings when
your thing is televised like the
drawings are for people who are like
reading about the trial they can't watch
it I got it okay I think that would make
more sense yeah I'm right let's dive
into some pop culture news are you are
you ready oh it is okay so here are the
past five stories that you uh need to
know today's episode is brought to you
by single drunk female on Hulu and
freeform Samantha Finks started from
Rock Bottom now she's here somewhere in
the middle from the executive producer
of girls comes the all-new season of
single drunk female on freeform and Hulu
she's 549 days sober and Counting things
are looking up for Sam it's the first
birthday that she's actually looked
forward to in forever and even if she's
spending her party hiding from everyone
in a closet she's on her way up
everything's coming up Sam she's living
with her overbearing mom still she's
trying to hold on to her not so dream
job where she writes the most important
listicles on the internet and she's
knocking on her ex's door at two in the
morning which is quite literally never a
good decision in case anybody didn't
know the show is fabulous everyone is
raving about it the guardian is calling
single drunk female a Next Level fleabag
refinery29 is raving calling it
refreshingly in your face and BuzzFeed
call Star Sophia Black Dalia a total
on-screen darling they dare you not to
fall in love with her everyone knows
your 20s can be wild and complicated and
being sober yeah even more so sometimes
quitters win this show is equal parts
hilarious and surprisingly emotional
don't miss the all new season you guys
know last year we were so excited about
the first season Jackie and I loved it
and now single drunk female on freeform
all the episodes are now streaming on
Hulu you don't want to miss it the show
is called single drunk female we're in
the second season and all the episodes
are now streaming on Hulu thank you Hulu
for not making us wait for episodes
today's episode is also brought to you
by betterhelp getting to know yourself
can be a lifelong process especially
because we're always growing and
changing and I feel like I'm just kind
of the embodiment of that I used to have
like such bad takes on pop culture a few
years ago so many different parts of my
life I'm so different now and
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and your understanding
because sometimes we don't know what we
want or why we react to the way that we
do until we talk through those things
better help connects you with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are so if you're thinking of
starting therapy you've been thinking
about it for a while you don't know
where to start try betterhelp this is a
great sign for you it's so accessible
it's so easy it's all done through your
phone it's done entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule so once you
match with a licensed therapist you
could text you can call you can video
chat whatever format you're most
comfortable with which I think is
awesome and also something I really like
about betterhelp as somebody who's done
therapy before
um you know when you match with a
therapist it's not always going to be a
match on the first hit a lot of people
shop around quote and better help makes
it so easy it's like not awkward like it
is in real life it's just really simple
if you want to switch it up it's not a
big deal and you'll get matched with a
new one you fill out a brief
questionnaire then you'll get matched
with a licensed therapist
um and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge discover
your potential with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp
help.com toast betterhelp.com t-o-a-s-t
some like hella dramatic news yesterday
but like very much boy who cried wolf
energy Drake Bell has addressed his
disappearance and just claims he left
his phone in his car okay I immediately
thought someone could not find their man
oh like he left his phone in his car
went missing like didn't come home like
there's a story there right and like the
local police department had put out an
alert like we are looking for Jared Bell
date of birth 627 his name was Jared no
[__] clue yeah so where did Drake
come from
I don't know whatever it was like all
this hoopla and then like hours later
it's like he's been found and everyone's
like thank God and then he tweeted
let me read it verbatim he said you
leave your phone in the car and don't
answer for the night and then this
crying Emoji who leaves their phone in
the car psychotic energy like that's
like having no social media Drake Bell
like is psychotic energy it's like crazy
allegations against him for like 16 15
year olds I didn't particularly care
when he was missing because I think he's
gross yeah um and I don't keep up I
wonder what the endangered part was I
don't know but he's like crazy fanatic
like fans oh really for what for just
like I think the the Drake Drake and
Josh era and then he had like a small
music career he's like a really Niche
audience of like diamonds I didn't know
he had a small music career yeah I mean
he sang the song Wait Drake and Josh
theme song I've met him what oh my God
wait Hannah interviewed him on our first
season of summer house for burning in
hell and it was and I came and like met
her there is a scene of the three of us
Drake Bell is on summer house yes
third season mine and Hannah's first
season that's the thing about like life
and pop culture it all comes back to
Bravo it really does I just remembered
that I also have a really horrible
memory so I like that really people say
it's from anxiety we block things out I
heard that it's from childhood trauma
like even though I can't think of any
type no because like I'm like did I that
was your instinct yeah to block things
out and now you're bringing that into
adulthood I tried asking my mom if I had
any and she goes I'll give you some
right now
I did everything I could for you she's
not wrong I'm okay these are what his
crazy fans had said because they were
like desperate for answers I was so
worried I felt physically sick when I
read the news this morning people love
and care about you more than you know a
second person added we were really
scared but it means we care a lot for
you no like I'm telling you he has like
these crazy ass fans I love Niche fans
me too and like toxic fans yeah like the
whole like Selena Haley thing some of
those fans were nutty deeply unwell
human beings yeah that was that was
almost infuriating what side were you on
where were you when Selena versus Haley
happened okay I had an unpopular opinion
everyone being like Haley is such a mean
girl and like how do you know that
though why because she's like tall and
pretty you think she's so mean right I
felt really bad for Haley that everyone
was coming at her I do like Selena but I
also I also felt like Selena's um
documentary was just like not what I was
expecting oh okay we recapted too I'm
trying to remember what my thought
thoughts were because it was kind of
forgettable but what what did you think
about it I just felt like it was it
skipped a lot of things yeah and like we
were watching it because we wanted to
know about the breakup with her and
Justin yeah of course and they never
touched on it but which I get from a PR
stance they've been kind of like teased
that they would right like it was just
it was during that time period so like
when she was sitting there like to
shoveling I wanted to be like well why
are you crying yeah well tell us about
it yeah so I just can't believe we're
still talking about this me and Jackie
felt the exact same like we were very
much like where is all this energy
coming for Haley she quite literally did
nothing this time around I don't I don't
know whatever I also didn't feel like
that Tick Tock was about Selena no and
we really felt like we loved Selena but
yeah she kind of fanned the Flames a
little bit like encouraging her fans to
be like she was commenting on people's
stuff right like you know I try not to
let this stuff bother yeah and it's like
that you're giving people permission
right to go exactly so and it was just
so crazy how every we got like attacked
for saying that really yeah no I have
the same opinion yeah I just felt it was
weird you kind of like a hilly Beaver of
Bravo wow yeah thank you very much like
Morgan Stewart to e like you to Bravo I
would die from Morgan Stewart I just
like love her Persona also on Instagram
because I feel like she doesn't care but
she's like effortlessly cool she doesn't
give a [__] she also stole my baby name
but that's here which one bro
um
do you have a relationship with Morgan
do you know her better oh really I think
you guys would get along like her but I
just think she's cool I mean I think
every I don't know a person out there
who doesn't think she's cool like Craig
interviewed her husband because he had a
I think an album coming out and he he
loved him what did he interview him for
he interviewed him on pillows and beer
um I don't think awesome was there it
was just Craig and he was either going
and like doing a concert or like had a
song coming out or a song just came out
something like that yeah no we I just
met him for the first time because I've
been friends with Morgan for a while and
I went to dinner with her when I was in
L.A and she brought her husband so I
brought Ben and they like love to golf
so if Craig golfs that's like a really
good point of entry Craig loves golf so
you should like get them to golf
together and then be like maybe Morgan
like we should get lunch
I feel like I'm a crazy Niche fan
I would love it I feel like she knows
that like people adore her and she like
lives for it I also think she's so funny
she's hysterical like I think her not
being on a red carpet for Oscars is like
a crime what is he doing I know what are
they doing I don't know how like
everyone everywhere managed to Fumble
the ball with Morgan Stewart right like
they I don't think he ever really put
her where she was like meant to be doing
they really do need to bring back
fashion police with her as the Joan and
I feel like yeah she could do that for
the next 20 30 years I would love it but
I feel like he's so scared to like
offend anything right even though it's
like literally dresses watching the
Oscars was painful Beyond everyone looks
beautiful she looks beautiful for her
what's the story with your outfit what's
the story yeah like tell us the story
your suit you're telling with the outfit
yeah
no red carpet coverage has gotten turned
it's so weird it's not right but I look
forward to seeing Drake Bell on a red
carpet coming soon because he is not
missing
time 100 our next story have released
their influential list and guess who's
number one who
what do you guess I love guessing wait I
act is it
um oh my God now I can't think of her
name from White Lotus yes she's number
one Jennifer Coolidge okay so she topped
the list she can't get over that she got
this like esteemed honor and she was
interviewed by Mia Farrow which seems
like so [__] random but whatever
um she cannot believe that she is having
this like moment of resurgence she she
spoke to me a pharaoh she said so many
of the qualities that have made everyone
fall oh no Mia Farrow said so many of
the qualities that have made everyone
fall in love with Jennifer Coolidge are
outside of what mainstream is expected
her eccentric mannerisms hilarious
improv and most of all her aching
vulnerability she is uncompromisingly
exquisitely herself it's actually so
true and I can't get over like the
journey that Jennifer Coolidge has been
on to me she will always be I hope we're
gonna say the same thing three two one A
Cinderella Story no Legally Blonde also
yeah you look like the Fourth of July I
actually forgot she was in a Cinderella
Story she's the evil stepmom yeah she's
amazing in that she's amazing in that
and there was like an era I would say
early 2000s where she was really popular
Legally Blonde
um of course Stifler's mom which I think
was her big thing and then there was
like kind of this Dead period for her
where I don't think she ever thought she
would come back and a lot of people
don't know this and I always feel like I
want to say it her Resurgence and she
gives a lot of credit it has a lot to do
with Ariana Grande
yes when Ariana Grande was on Jimmy
Fallon yes yep she was like I'm obsessed
with Jennifer Coolidge I think they
brought Jennifer Coolidge out at one
point she did her Jennifer Coolidge
impersonation and Ariana just brought
Jennifer Coolidge just a young audience
who didn't know her and Jennifer has
spoken publicly about like so much of
what's happening to her right now was
kind of like the the spark was started
by Ariana Grande I love that I know how
nice of Ariana Grande I wonder if they
like our friends I have to assume that
they are yeah and so this is what she
had to say about like her Resurgence as
a 61 year old it's like I was Sleeping
Beauty where I was locked in this box
under the bed or something and now I'm
out and it's like well I'm sure glad
they let me out of that box because this
is way better she's so I'm so happy for
her I know is she married I don't know I
don't know a lot about her personal life
let me look it up I don't even know does
she have kids right like I would love to
like see paparazzi photos of her out on
the town in L.A like out to dinner okay
she is
she doesn't have kids and she is single
okay wow I kind of love that we could
get like a single era yes I would love
to know like who
yeah what's her type and who has their
eye on her I also love that they chose
her because it's kind of not so obvious
these they chose Michael B Jordan Doja
cat Bob Iger king of Disney and I feel
like a lot of these are like kind of
obvious but Jennifer Coolidge isn't who
you would think except so immediately
yeah I love her I love that too and the
other people included on the list are
Austin Butler Zoe Saldana Angela Bassett
because she did the thing Aubry Plaza
Colin Farrell Drew Barrymore this is
like very kind of generic Ali Wong Salma
Hayek Patrick Mahomes Lionel Messi
Brittany Greiner Beyonce they put
Brittany grinding her twice
um I'm usually uninspired by the time
100 list yeah and I don't see any
influencers when it's literally the most
influential people I was just gonna say
I'm surprised like Alex Earl isn't on
there oh my God would you say that Alex
Earl is the most influential person
right now
that her or the octopus guy what are
your thoughts on him I love him I love
him I really do they did something where
the caption was like when the popular
girl and the class clown get here
together and that is their energy that
is their energy Alex Earl is such an
anomaly to me it's so crazy it's so fun
to watch I'm looking at this list by the
way and I do not see any impossible
managed in all the fame she's just
gotten in the past couple of months
managed to give the same content she did
from before see that's like the toxic
cycle of influence is like you blow up
because you're so relatable yeah and so
much about Alex just being a college
girl who like wore crop tops and did her
makeup living in a house with six girls
and they have tiny bedrooms was so
relatable yeah but then your
relatability causes you to become rich
and famous and being rich and famous is
not relatable so then people start to
hate you whenever I post something
that's even a little bit expensive I get
nervous yeah but I'm like but I want to
show you what I bought no I know and
it's like you're proud but that cycle
like it doesn't work right so Alex
Journal has actually done an amazing job
I agree her content has remained totally
the same and even now she's on her way
to Coachella and the brand Guess flew
her private and she gets off this
private plane and there's an element of
course to Flying private that's so
unrelatable and unattainable but she
made this hilarious Tick Tock from the
scene from Hannah Montana when she gets
off the private plane hello New York and
then she's actually in Tennessee so
she's actually I don't even know if
she's doing it on purpose but she's very
smart about like the angle at which
she's sharing her life I feel like she's
not even doing it on purpose like she's
just being her and I feel like that's
what people are loving I know it's so
fascinating me too and I've met her and
she's so nice oh good she's not like a
ditch [__] Diva like she's so down to
earth so normal like almost I want to
say like shy because sometimes I don't
trust a blonde so true sometimes you got
to be a little weary would you ever go
blonde yes I would you would yeah I've
always wanted okay in high school I
wanted to be a redhead so bad then like
redheads are having a moment Hannah just
like kind of dyed her hair a little bit
red
I have always wanted to be like a bleach
bleach blonde but I feel like I would
ruin my real color and I do like my real
color you would ruin your real color I
also feel like that's so not you yeah
I feel like it's so easy to be blonde I
wore a wig for Halloween one year and I
just immediately started acting
different I was different I was like
this is they're right they have more fun
like it's different they do have more
fun other than that yeah Alex Earl
definitely looks like she's having a
blast yeah she has way more fun than I
do but I think that's because she's
literally 19. oh yeah and she's like
perfect looking and like no she's just
literally perfect looking it's just not
fair yeah I can't compare myself like to
Alex Earl all good yeah no I feel like a
mom oh it's so depressed myself to her
I'm like oh I remember when I went out
in college back in the day I know
doesn't it like make you so sad yeah
something about I think the I think
turning 30 and like approaching 30 for
everyone is really difficult but being
in the digital space where it's like the
younger you are the cooler you are yeah
I'm struggling with it so much like it's
killing me I had a real hard time
turning 30 and all of my friends who had
turned 30 were like you're being so
dramatic like it's it's fine it's the
same thing as 29. I did not think it was
the same I still hate it I do not like
being 30. no I'm I'm approaching like
I'm having a tough time but the one
thing my one girlfriend said is she had
a hard time turning 30 but she said 30
to 33 is the same so you like have a
little recruiting for the next time
you're so old I know I I swear to God I
just turned 21. I just turned 21. how
old do you feel if you didn't know you
were 29. that's a good question I feel
25 26 and that's because that's how old
I was when the pandemic started
oh and I had I had such good years taken
for me I entered the pandemic at 25 and
by the time it was truly over I was 28.
okay that's interesting I would say that
I feel 27. you'd look 27. thank you
talking about age like I'm I'm sure
that's like a trigger for me me too I
don't like so glad you're on the same
page because I'm not one of these people
it's like ages December it's not no it's
not it's so don't you feel like gen Z
like comes way harder at us than we ever
came for like no I think we came for
them too and now we're getting our
comeuppance I don't know I feel like gen
Z is like really mean the way gen Z like
kind of judges and I don't really like
to call myself a millennial yeah because
in a way now I'm not saying but you're
at the very end of Millennia I'm really
close to like being a border okay and
I'm still not on the border but I'm just
close to the border so I don't really
like to call myself a millennial like
and I don't I don't identify with
Millennials at all I heard someone refer
to us as the
um Spice Girl Generation and I will now
be going back that works for me I love a
platform issue you see Spice World the
moving a thousand times did you have
nightmares growing up that you would
open the toilet and someone's head would
pop out yeah I never understood that
part like why were they ever at that
house no no what was that boot camp
Community made no [__] sense but I
will say I did a um a project in the
10th grade in my physics class about how
you had to take a scene from a movie
where they do like a stunts and like
project the velocity based like and see
if they if it could actually happen in
real life okay you know the scene where
they're driving on their big double
decker bus and the London Bridge is
opening and they jump over the bridge I
did in my physics class could that
actually
velocity-wise based on the mass of what
a typical bus weighs right and it
obviously could not be done and I got an
A wow so I had never really gone into
anything new Posh Spice thank you so
even though the movie made no [__]
sense yeah it did kind of save me in a
way it also like set the tone of Our
Generation it definitely did and it was
like iconic looks and the inside of the
bus oh my God all I wanted was a bus all
I wanted was that bus with like their
little bunk beds and like the fire pole
like I wanted that bus service yes I
love them today's episode is brought to
you by Topgolf Topgolf is everything
because it's golf it's not golf it's
Topgolf they've got a bunch of stuff
that makes them golf you know the clubs
the balls the t's the turf the ball
picker upper thing they also have a
bunch of stuff that makes it knock off
they've got great music giant Targets in
the Fairway huge TVs handcrafted food
and beverage menu and when you put all
those things Under One Roof you got
yourself a pretty good time consider
this your formal invitation to grab the
family a few friends or some co-workers
and come play around I have been to
Topgolf in Nashville and actually when
we go back to Nashville in a few weeks
we already made a reservation to hit up
the Topgolf because we're going to be
with all of our husbands and boyfriends
we thought it'd be a really good place
for both the boys and the girls to chill
even though last time we went we were on
a girls trip and we were like should we
do Topgolf and most of us hadn't been
there we had the best time the food and
beverage were so good we just like ate
and drank a ton but the golf was so fun
we got like really weirdly into it and
competitive that's like kind of on brand
for me that's something I always do like
I am gonna ruin a good time by being
competitive and of course Jackie won
because life is unfair so if you don't
play golf it doesn't matter everyone can
play tough guy Topgolf even if you can't
swing a club the food and beverages are
so good it's the only place Topgolf
where you can play around and then order
around it's also really comfortable it's
all the fun of outside but with all the
Comforts of inside it's comfortable it's
heated in the winter the bays are cooled
in the summer last time we went it was
kind of chilly and it was really warm
and this time we're going it's going to
be hot and I feel like it's such a good
decision to go to Topgolf because the
bays are cooled so you know me I'm very
temperature conscious like I can't I
can't do that you know and I really
appreciate Topgolf being temperature
conscious too it's golf it's not golf
it's Topgolf download the app book a bay
and come play around okay I'm sure
you're keeping abreast with scandival
yes as a Bravo Liberty yourself do you
have any like established relationships
with any of the major parties in this
Saga so I texted Ariana oh
um I really like Ariana I'm actually I
talked to her best friend a lot his name
is Logan he's like randomly sometimes on
the show yeah so when it like first
happened I didn't reach out to her
because I was just like that just seems
rude overwhelming of course I texted
Logan first and I was like what's
happening tell me everything and it was
everyone was just so shocked and sad and
then I did text her and I was like they
did you a favor I am so sorry like I
can't imagine
um did she respond yeah and she was like
thank you so much that means a lot like
I just shocking yeah and I talked to
Sheena a little bit she was giving me
like a little gossip just how she like
lived in sheena's house I didn't know
that who Raquel
lives in Gina's house for a little bit
that's crazy and she was like she was
staying with me but like having this
affair with Tom like that's just so
insane I don't know if there will ever
be a day where I get over this
it's just okay then I did hit a point
where I started to feel bad for Raquel
Because the Internet Was vicious
because it was you know when something
happens in Bravo and it's it's Bravo
people it's insular yes and sometimes I
like if something happens to me or Craig
Craig will always be like we this is
Niche not everyone knows Bravo like you
gotta get out of it you have to have
perspective but then this happened and I
was like this was on CNN global global
news but he knows about it a hundred
percent and so I started having like
second-hand anxiety for Raquel yeah I
was like how are you even how could you
even be on your phone I actually sent
her a DM being like if you need help
like you need to be okay to ask for it
like this is not a normal thing people
should go through no that's fair on
social media she didn't respond but I
just felt like this overwhelming feeling
of like what if she scared something
happened yeah I know you know the
internet so fast and so Furious yes and
to be on the receiving end of it which
obviously I don't think anybody's been
on the receiving end of what probably
Raquel is receiving but I've been on the
receiving end of much smaller versions
of it it's crippling yeah especially if
you're person and I assume she is
because she's a reality star like yeah
you put stock in what other people think
about you yeah some people really don't
give a [__] genuinely yeah I'm not that
person I am not that person I don't
think if you go on a reality show you
really are that person no I don't know
if I've heard people like that exist I
haven't met it I don't think that that
is a real thing I think people can have
this like really intense false
confidence mine like caps at a certain
level no I uh 100 like when people are
like don't look at the comments I'm like
how
so the story that everyone's talking
about you know Lala was on um watch
Robin's live yes and she she's one of
the people that I feel like really
doesn't give a shout no actually I agree
like about what people think of but is
it false confidence I don't know I think
she I've been in rooms with her I really
do feel like she doesn't care she walks
the walk and she talks yeah yeah I get
that Vibe too but you never know I'm
like how do you do that you really never
know someone no that's true well she's
teasing like this big conversation that
apparently happens in the finale she
says you guys are going to die there's
one conversation in the final episode
she's sick and he said confirming yeah
it's really upsetting and apparently
what I've read is that at the end Ariana
is having a conversation with Raquel
just kind of confiding in her that like
things with Tom are like not good and
she's like really anxious that he's
cheating on her and Raquel like sits
there and Pat her back and he's like no
you're fine
wait that's crazy I know
I feel like okay I've met Raquel I would
say maybe
two three times always very lovely
always very nice I always chalked it up
to like oh she's a very La girly like
she does like she's very a little bit
air different yeah like she doesn't yeah
she's very like flower chat like yeah
like oh my God hey hippie so I actually
don't know if she like gets it like I
don't know if she like people are like
she has to be a sociopath I don't think
she's a sociopath I think she doesn't
know what's happening I also think she
doesn't really know how to pick up on
like any sort of social cues or like I
don't think she has any sense of like
social decorum and like how things work
um and I've been around people like that
and you get mad and then you have to
like feel bad because you're like oh you
don't know what's going on you quite
literally can't participate in this
scenario you have no idea what's like at
a top level like what's really going on
yeah and I there's a lot of people on
reality TV that are like that and
honestly I feel like in a way maybe it's
not on purpose but it definitely is like
a form of protection when you guys
really know what the [__] is happening
that's
him really ever get hurt like I don't
think she's is really that hurt yeah
like social media because she doesn't
really know she I don't yeah and I I I'm
sure people around her are instructing
her to actually stay off her phone yes
even though it's so like leave it in the
car for the night take a note from Drake
Bell like 100 so random but this just
reminded me what are your thoughts on
bravocon now being in Vegas they just
announced that right yes I at first was
like oh man yeah yeah that's a lot but
it's probably good because that's like
what Vegas does they do conventions yeah
like they know how to do that for
thousands and thousands of people I felt
very claustrophobic having it in New
York yeah I think they tapped out in
terms of capacity it being in New York
like just even in terms of like hotels
and stuff yeah I don't think it was
really feasible to go any longer and
that Saturday night of bravocon is oh
wait did they say the dates oh I don't
know okay maybe don't spoil that then
what is it I really want to know my
birthday oh that's something and then
people would know that but I guess like
being in there are worse places to be
than they Vegas for your birthday
absolutely and Craig gets to be there
because he's on Bravo it's actually kind
of fun
it will be fun because I also refused to
do anything for my 30th birthday oh
right because it was a dark side yeah so
this will be like my 30th you're 29th
yeah this is my 29th birthday happy 29th
birthday cage okay A little moronic news
but I feel like I need to talk about it
even though I don't believe it Kylie
Jenner's car has been spotted at Timothy
chalamet's house after like it was
announced on dumois that they were
dating yeah so they're adding rumors
about their supposed romance her car was
in the driveway of his Beverly Hills
Home her Black Range Rover pulled up to
Timothy's sprawling estate on Thursday
afternoon the internet is going crazy
about it her car pulled in from the road
drove straight up the winding driveway
basically to his house and now people
are going back and like looking at
footage they were both at Paris fashion
week and nobody thought anything of it
but they appear to be like smiling at
each other I don't know how everyone
knows it like this particular Range
Rover belongs to Kylie Jenner but this
does have Kris Jenner written all over
it so she wants us to know like this is
happening yes
you know they're like friends that you
have or you're like I just can't picture
you ever having sex yes or Kylie
um them together for me it's Timothy
chalamet because he quite literally
looks 11. I can't picture him like
behind her yeah Lincoln really throws me
for a loop or like I can't really
picture him like taking charge yeah like
I can't picture him grabbing her face
and making out with her yeah and I can't
imagine like Kylie enjoying that I just
don't I don't see it well Jackie and I
talk a lot on the toast about how
Kardashians are very much in this flop
era yeah they're kind of like irrelevant
um and I think very slowly they're doing
small things to to get back on top I
think part of that was Kylie uh Kendall
Jenner and Bad Bunny which I think was
like actually a great I was really here
for it so
and I think this is a little bit part of
that too like getting associated with
like very well-liked people like Bad
Bunny liked him in jail my I'm sorry I
don't know there's something so not
believable about this I think North has
like two more years of being a child
before Kris Jenner pulls her in for a
meeting yeah no I think like once her
sweet 16 happens she's officially on the
books like she's on the clock like
you're gen Z you better be reigning gen
Z Queen and you know they're kind of
setting the scene for North on Tick Tock
and Penelope because Northern Penelope
are similar ages they're both like young
adults no not young adults they're like
39. they're so [__] Advanced they're
so mature like when Penelope does her
skincare routine it's 45 steps but have
you watched North's with like a saint
and um Chicago yes she's so I wasn't
expecting her to be so nice and like
calming and like she's a sweetie she's
so cute she's like okay Chicago it's
your turn now like yeah that's so cute I
feel like she has like kind of a diva uh
what's what I'm looking for
um Persona no like people think
reputation yeah just because she was
like the first for Kim yeah she's like I
don't know I just I'm all Kanye yeah
right I would just think she's like
gonna be a diva like she shows up in all
black to Easter I've been at home like
that's Kanye West but when she speaks
I'm like oh man you're not what yeah I
thought you would be yes like a really
caring older sister I do feel like Kim
nothing didn't know her or anything but
I do feel like she's a good mom I know
me too like I do get those vibes I feel
like it's all she cares about yeah and I
feel like Chloe is too I feel like
Courtney's kind of like do whatever yeah
like there's always like that one cousin
that like their mom lets them do
whatever they want totally that's like
Mason and Penelope did you watch their
Hulu wedding special I didn't me neither
I just didn't
care but I do think it was really
interesting I want to pull this up
because everyone was like oh the girl
who's been complaining for years about
filming and you know having to put her
personal life out there is now doing a
spin-off I think people were like and I
that was my my reaction on the show so I
was like this just seems like a little
inauthentic I'm also terrified of
Alabama Barker oh yeah like if she
wanted to punch me in the face I'd say
go for it but then yesterday Courtney
posted to promote the wedding thing and
look at her caption it was so long she
was kind of explaining herself so she
said all the footage used in our
documentary till death do us part is our
personal footage that we later decided
to edit into a perfect little mini film
our Vegas wedding was shot on this our
Santa Barbara wedding was shot by our
friend so when we were asked about
filming our wedding in Italy our
decision was that we didn't want the
show's cameras there and I'm so happy
with that decision we had the iconic
Ellen Von unworth in Italy to help us
Capture Moments she's just basically
explaining it there were no show cameras
there was just standard wedding
videographers okay that they then turned
into some sort of wedding special okay
so she had to explain herself yeah they
must have
me neither I'm not reading that whole
thing and I didn't read the whole thing
the first time around either I just I
can't if you can't say it in like 400
characters or less then maybe it's not
worth saying
no literally it's not worth saying
people that like write
who has the time like oh my God this is
our like two year anniversary and like
all these things if Craig ever wrote a
caption that was more than two sentences
about me I would send a breakup text
okay I will say there is only one
instance where you can write as long as
you want and that's when you're
commemorating a death okay I agree with
it because they're really a person can
only cannot be limited to a caption I'm
not coming for them no so if you died
Craig could write however long for sure
but until then as long as you're kicking
two sentences or less but if he also did
R.I.P dude I'd be that's also me and
Jack are always saying like
social media is like kind of made like
commemorating the deaths of people so
weird because people will just be like
rip yeah like that and yeah thanks yeah
no no that's really beautiful yeah thank
you for taking the time you don't even
capitalize all the I and the P it's just
rip
it's kind of just it makes me uncomfy I
know
um okay but the final story is kind of
probably like the most moronic thing
you've ever heard in your life another
fire Festival is happening says con
artist and convicted felon Billy
McFarland oh my gosh he's promising that
there's gonna be a fire Festival too he
um tweeted fire Festival two is finally
happening tell me why you should be
invited do you want him to date Anna
delve I mean it's too obvious like it's
too perfect I mean now that is a reality
show I would watch yeah but she can't
leave her house so he's gonna spend time
in yeah have you been invited to any of
her like socialite dinner parties at her
house she's been doing this thing no
she's been doing like underground like
Supper Club where she can't leave her
house so she has people come to her
house and it's like you know interesting
influential people and different in the
Arts in sports or whatever if you gotten
have you been invited if you got invited
would you go a hundred percent you would
yeah and I believe you can't film but
like I will be wearing spyware all over
my office see I don't know I can't even
go to like influencer events unless I
know at least two people going totally
so like I don't think I could go to that
by myself it's a once in a lifetime
chance like it's something you would
tell your grandchildren about you'd have
to go I mean her Vogue photo shoot on
her roof was iconic yeah I was surprised
they let her go to the roof I thought
you couldn't really leave like the
perimeter of your building apartment I'm
just very fascinated by her yeah did you
watch inventing Anna yeah of course oh
the reason I brought up this fire
episode things because like as an
influencer it's very possible that like
the first go-around you could have been
asked and paid yeah to have promoted it
yes first of all that was before you
were on Bravo right
I can't remember how long ago was it
2000 it was a while I want to say it was
before it was the or I'd like done my
first summer yeah like I had like I
wasn't getting invited anywhere well I
had been influencing at the time and I
was like now I look back and I'm like
thank God like I if somebody would have
offered to pay me I would have been like
yeah sure promote a music festival like
I had a group of friends who
legitimately bought tickets I'm like
that way really and we're stuck in the
Bahamas no yeah and we're trying to get
like private planes like gay were they a
part of like the class action lawsuit I
don't think they like did anything I
know someone actually it's like someone
Ben knows who was a part of the class he
was like one of like the actual like
victims and he was a part of the class
action and he does not talk about it I
think he got a [__] ton of money he
doesn't talk about it but it's because
it's private wow I know where is Ja Rule
what's he think the thing is about jab
rule in his words he was Hoodwinked and
Bamboozled and we've all been there yeah
no we really have no and like for me
especially with some things like work
wise I'm just like yeah I don't read it
I'm like yeah sure so I could totally
like I could understand Ja Rule's
position I really yeah I can too I
cannot understand Billy McFarland's
position I can't believe there's anyone
that's like teaming up with him to do it
again to me like and this is how the
world is so small one of my favorite
things is like Mike The Situation was
actually in prison with Billy McFarland
he met him like that's just why being a
fan of pop culture is so incredible I
love that I know nobody gives Jersey
Shore the credit they deserve actually
on television for almost 20 years the
toast does dude oh thank you for doing
the Lord's work I re-watch a show
every couple of years it's the best show
ever like those early seasons are yes
I'm sorry no reality show
can compare I was a senior in high
school when it first came out and it
shaped everything about my college Years
yep it was my whole personality it was
my entire we had a famous people party
in my senior year in high school and I
went as Snooki and I made my boyfriend
go as like the situation it was the best
night of my life I'd still think about
it so similarly I mean I went to a
Jewish Day School and it came out when I
was in the 10th grade so for perum I
dressed up as Snooki and I also ran for
Student Government I did lose but my
campaign was GTL gym Torah and learning
and I made posters with um my face like
cropped into snookies I was obsessed
that's that's amazing I've I've always
loved her like she is the show for me
she is she will go down in history as
one of the most legendary reality stars
and no one gives her credit that she's
still married yeah Gianni and they all
doubted yeah
they're like you're being crazy whatever
you messed up he broke up with you and
then them getting married I just I mean
that Florence season when he was so
[__] toxic and she was just running
home from the club every night to get on
that duck phone like remember when Mike
banged his head into the wall I mean the
concrete wall like these people were not
[__] normal and they're still on TV I
know they have the reunion show I don't
watch it but people like it I haven't
watched it since they left no the shore
no but did you ever watch um stinky and
Jay Wow's spin-off yes where they lived
in that Firehouse
that was just a core memory for me it
got renewed it's coming back and they're
moving in together I don't think they're
going to be moving in together but they
got their own spin-off okay I think they
should have one that was the CR and they
were pregnant she was one of them was
pregnant when they were living in the
firehouse yes and they went to some
restaurant where the people would scare
you and that's like all I remember from
one of the episodes and it was just like
this random Firehouse in New Jersey I
feel connected to them because I feel
like they met on the show and became
really good friends and that's how I
feel with Hannah yeah like something
you're doing this very weird thing that
no one can really relate to like you're
my lifeline and then there's no like
breaking that Bond who is the Snooki and
who is the jwow between you and Hannah
I think I would say that I'm probably
the j-wow and she's the Snooki I would
agree
yeah because I can get more mad than
Hannah like will
J was [__] scary like I will never
cross her is from where I'm from she's
from Albany she's from
um like a town over I think and she went
to a high school called Columbia High
School oh my God that's iconic and I was
like oh icons only coming from Albany
who's like a famous alumni from your
high school
um besides you no one from my high
school but Jimmy Fallon went to my
college which was in Albany where'd you
go to college it was called the College
of St Rose yeah if I I went to NYU like
every famous person like doesn't count
but Natasha Leone did go to my high
school who is that
she's obviously not really famous
um did you ever watch Orange is the New
Black
yes the blonde girl oh okay crazy hair
yes and um I don't see her as a Natasha
I know I don't see her as a Jew yeah I
went to a Jewish school I didn't know
that she was Jewish yeah and man
repeller
okay she went to my high school as well
just kind of like and a few like people
who now like I don't know like work in
politics I I troll the like famous
alumni portion of my school's Wikipedia
page yeah nobody has added me and it's
devastating
oh my God I just went into had to talk
at my college That's so exciting it was
so exciting but I was so nervous because
I was like this is like a very
professional setting did you speak to a
class
um they set up like a little stage and
like clap like classes would come and
people like random people would come and
I was so nervous just like my time in
college and like how I went from like
that to being on reality TV which I like
I like was it a moderated it's so
important to constantly be lying it is
was it a moderated conversation yes
there was a professor like asking me
questions and he had to listen to giggly
Squad episodes and this is like a I mean
this man was like in his 50s he was like
a true not your target demo yeah not my
target demo and he was like I am a
giggler thank you and I was like I love
you deceased oh my god well Peggy yes
it's been absolutely delightful having
you thank you for having me thank you
for breaking down the stories with
passion and vigor and it's just it's
exciting to talk to somebody who is as
excited about like nothing as I am you
know and the bad so where can everyone
follow you they want to keep up
um Paige underscore desorbo is my
Instagram does somebody own Paige
disorder without the underscore
I don't know I but I liked having the
space Oh okay so that was a personal
choice same as my Instagram or same as
my Tick Tock and then giggly Squad is
every Tuesday every Tuesday and the
clips are killing it I'm caggling well
we were watching your clip your guys
clips and we were like they're so good
like we need to be more everything Clips
are everything I love Clips I'll clip
some stuff like this who knows
that's our show you guys thank you for a
great week of friends and family we're
back with Jackson Claude next week so
have a great weekend thank you so much
for listening to the testimony Morning
Show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so at Spotify iTunes digital
public radio I already cast box all the
places where we listen to podcast review
about a beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have a
great weekend stay safe and we'll see
you on Monday bye have you ever done an
auction